دبابات وليوبارتوال المانيه ترفض برلين
تسليمها الى كياب قبل التشاور مع واشنطن
وفقم اعلنه المستشار الالماني او لاف شولد
ولكن لماذا يرفض شولد تسليما دبابات
ليوبارتو بعد ان تحركت فرنسا وبريطانيا
وبولندا نحو تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
القتاليه
برلين تقول انه يجب مناقشه ارسال الدبابات
الغربيه مع الرئاسه الامريكيه ومع
الاصدقاء والحلفاء وهذا الامر يجب ان يتم
عبر التحالف دوليه المانيا لا تريد الدخول
في مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا لان الدبابات
تعتبر من الاسلحه التصعيديه وفق خبراء
عسكريين بولندا بدورها اتخذت قرار تسليم
اوكرانيا دبابات ليوبار تو ولكن هذه
الخطوه لن تتم فعليا لان المانيا تتحكم في
رخصه تصديره جميع دبابات ليوبارد 2 اما
فرنسا فقد اعلنت سابقا على لسان رئيسها
امامك هذا مدرعات قتاليه من طراز اي ام
اكس ان ار سي
في المقابل اقترحتك يا هذا ان ترسل
الولايات المتحده عددا ولو قليلا من
الدبابات من اجل تحفيز اوروبا على التحرك
سريعا من اجل حسم الحرب
ارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا لن يؤديا سوى
الى اطاله معاناه الشعب الاوكراني ولا
يغير من نتيجه الحرب تقول روسيا ردا على
القرارات الغربيه محاسن حداره العربيه
[موسيقى]